les européennes simone veil tête de
liste centriste souhaite une europe plus
sociale plus humaine elle l'a dit dans
un entretien publié ce matin par nos
confrères de l'est républicain
l'europe sociale précisément au centre
des débats des partis socialistes et
sociaux démocrates européens et des
syndicats qui étaient réunis aujourd'hui
à la cité des sciences à la villette à
paris à l'initiative de laurent fabius
une étape dans sa campagne avec le
soutien de michel rocard et de pierre
mauroy
eric héraud c'est l'option de français
italiens espagnols sociaux démocrates
allemands anglais et de tous les autres
pays de la cee se sont succédé à la
tribune toute la journée pour affirmer
leur volonté de construire l'europe
sociale avec des craintes dans un
premier temps en essais la concurrence
et les restructurations dues à la
suppression des frontières risque de
faire augmenter le chômage mais avec des
espoirs aussi dans un deuxième temps le
grand marché intérieur devrait permettre
la création de 2 à 5 millions d'emplois
dans les états membres
tous les responsables ont également
souligné leur volonté d'harmoniser la
protection des travailleurs dans tous
les pays d'europe
on les alignant pas vers le bas mais au
contraire en garantissant les droits qui
existent déjà et en en créant de
nouveaux laurent fabius tête de liste
des socialistes français a dénoncé je
cite l'autre conception de l'europe
l'europe libérale de margaret thatcher
et des autres responsables conservateurs
européens
on ne peut pas pour nos 10 être
conservateur dans son pays et
progressiste
lorsqu'il s'agit de l'europe si on veut
clairement une europe de progrès social
à l'heure ce sont évidemment les
socialistes et les sociaux démocrates
qui sont le plus capable de construire
cette europe là socialistes et sociaux
démocrates se sont fixés ce soit en
lançant un appel aux travailleurs appel
en faveur d'un avenir de progrès
économique et de justice sociale